hmm excuse me let's stay with that story
and enjoy now by dr. Robert Kelly he's
professor is a professor of
international relations at Pusan
National University and Busan in South
Korea thank you for joining us and good
morning to you why does North Korea need
to carry out these tests and indeed why
does it carry on with these tests sure
um the North Koreans have decided that
nuclear weapons were the best way to
prevent them from being attacked by the
United States myself Korea the North
Koreans have learned from watching the
United States and Iraq and Libya and
other places in the last 20 years have
decided that a conventional deterrent is
not enough and that they need nuclear
weapons they obviously don't have an Air
Force what they have is very old and so
this is what they keep testing rockets
eventually they want to marry the
nuclear warhead to the rocket and do you
think that is likely to happen I do the
North Koreans have come a lot further
than a lot of us expected on the North
Koreans have done a remarkably good job
actually rather quite astonishing
actually how well they've done in
developing these weapons over the last
25 years as everybody knows have been
enormous efforts made to sanction them
and block them from quiring these things
and a lot of this is done through the
black market that really cut off from a
great deal lisset trade and they still
managed to pull it off so I wouldn't be
surprised at all they managed to do this
in the next few years and it would
suggest doctor that the sanctions really
aren't working would it not yeah that
there's a big discussion about that i
would just what i would say is i would
defend the sanctions by saying that if
we didn't have them a probably even
worse part of the palm also is that some
countries specifically china haven't
cooperated terribly well with sanctions
in the past now we have had a new wave
of sanctions since the tests in
january-february I'm more optimistic
about those because I think they target
on North Korea's money which i think is
pretty important for it to raise to
acquire these parts so a little bit
optimistic this time so what do you
think the response is going to be
following these these tests today um
well I mean they're probably some kind
of you in action as they're usually SW
denunciations from the United States and
Japan and South Korea as they're usually
are the big questions of course will be
do the Chinese respond and do the
Russians upon what will they say and I
think the Chinese particularly that's
the one that's most important i do think
that's Chinese are getting close to the
end of the rope with North Korea this is
always very hard to gauge but my sense
is that the Chinese are losing their
patients this is
they're going to pull the plug on North
Korea or something like that but that's
the real response to watch for the next
you know say week so do you think if the
Chinese do get on board the these tests
would actually stop no but I do think
the Chinese public slow them down
significantly and raise the cost
significantly um and if the Chinese were
actually generally really forced a
breach between themselves in North Korea
I think that would be the death knell to
regime I think that's really the problem
right I think the North Koreans would
keep going so long as they believe that
the environment around them is so
threatening they have to have these
weapons this is I think one of the
reasons why the Obama administration we
found out tried to secretly start a deal
with the North Koreans in late December
they're trying to sort of um push the
North Koreans away from going through
these tests but as long as the North
Koreans feel like they need these things
they're going to keep going I just don't
think the Chinese can provide that kind
of existential security guarantee he'll
still go for weapons nuclear weapons
because it just it doesn't seem that
they're really concerned about raising
tensions whether it's in the region or
further abroad they've just sentenced an
American to 15 years i believe it is of
hard labor why do you think it is that
they just don't seem to care kim jong
un's government just doesn't seem to
care yeah that's actually a really good
question not entirely sure myself my own
sense is that the North Koreans have
gotten accustomed to being coddled um
that is to say that the North Koreans
during the Cold War for example they
were the bounce back and forth between
the Soviets and the Chinese and they're
able to do all kinds of stuff and they
didn't really pay very healthy um in the
last 25 years or so i think the North
Koreans have gotten away with a great
deal of stuff that many other states in
the world didn't if you look at what
happens they like the dictators of
Yugoslavia or rack we look at the way
the United States has responded to other
problems in the Middle East and the
North Koreans have never actually felt
that stick and so I think the North
Koreans think that they have more room
maybe than they do but to certain extent
the Chinese have provided them with that
room the Chinese have sort of generally
refused to release or clamp down and
push hard on north korea regarding the
rocket tests in the nuclear test because
they're afraid North Korea's going to
implode and so it's a difficult in back
it's difficult balance the Chinese right
well they push the North Koreans enough
to actually get some results about
bringing the collapse of the regime